remember when XCOM 2 got that puppy gun
mod well the mods aren't stopping
anytime soon and while the aliens next
come aren't Gungans or wookies there is
a mod out there to turn your squad into
some of Star Wars most infamous Gunners
a steam user by the name of platoon has
released the Star Wars helmets mod
download it and you'll be able to outfit
your soldiers with the helmets of
classic and first-order stormtroopers
scout troopers republic clone troopers
and even Boba Fett a bit of face paint
will keep the whole look consistent if
you want to take the cosplay even
further you can grab voice packs from
the Steam Workshop you can bark your
orders as a Twi'lek sev from republic
commando or once again the great Boba
Fett somebody really likes bounty
hunters XCOM 2 has been experiencing
performance issues but developer fire
axis is working to squash any bugs in
the meantime you can still decorate your
game with plenty of mods like this when
we hear about more crazy mods or
important game updates will tell you all
about it on gamespot
you